President Trump will not be getting the
big Veterans Day military parade he
wanted the parade was canceled when the
cost was estimated at more than 90
million dollars mr. Trump called that
price tag ridiculously high and that of
course led to another war of words Kris
Van Cleave reports President Donald
Trump's bastille day inspired grand
military parade will have to wait
announcing on twitter the local
politicians who run washington DC poorly
no a windfall when they see it when
asked to give us a price for holding a
great celebratory military parade they
wanted a number so ridiculously high
that I cancelled it DC Mayor Muriel
Bowser
who is not a trump supporter shot back
saying she's the local politician who
finally got through to the reality star
in the White House with the realities
21.6 million of parades events
demonstrations in Trump America sad the
city's estimate included thirteen point
four million dollars for DC police and
nearly 3.6 million for fire and
emergency services Pentagon sources
confirm the total estimated cost of the
parade was 92 million dollars about the
cost of an f-35 fighter 15 Black Hawk
helicopters or 61 Tomahawk cruise
missiles the American Legion called for
the money to be spent on funding the VA
instead of a parade the president said
he wanted a parade but the price tag
would be a deciding factor
we'll see if we could do it at a
reasonable cost and if we can't we won't
do it oh I think Kansas in the frame is
exactly the right thing to do Rhode
Island senator Jack Reed is a former
Army Ranger 90 million dollars on a
parade is an extravagance that the
military can't afford
more of scale military parades are rare
in the United States the last one was
1991 following the Gulf War it cost an
estimated eight million dollars a figure
that drew protests mr. Trump said he
would attend a military parade at nearby
Joint Base Andrews and he is planning to
travel to France for a world war one
celebration in parade in November he did
not rule out the possibility of a parade
happening here in DC next year for CBS
this morning Saturday Kris Van Cleave
Washington